- Most people look at law school
as some inscrutable ivory tower.
As a result, there are
a huge number of myths
about what happens when
you start law school.
So today let's talk about some
of the three biggest myths
about starting law school
and why they're wrong.
So let's dive into the biggest myths
about starting law school.
The first myth is, "Everybody
knows what they want to do
"when they graduate."
In reality, very few
people go to law school
knowing exactly what they
want to do when they graduate
from law school.
You may have a general idea that you want
to go into public interest law,
or you want to become a civil litigator,
or you want to go into criminal defense.
But very few people know
exactly the sub field,
exactly the firm that they want to go to.
In fact, most people will
change their conception
of what they want to
do when they graduate.
So don't be afraid to go to law school
not knowing exactly which firm
and which section of
law you want to practice
when you graduate.
In reality, very few
people know exactly what
they want to do and those
things change over time.
Now on the other hand, you
should have a general idea
and you should be damn sure
that you definitely want
to be a lawyer or you
want to go into some field
that requires a law degree
before you go to law school.
It's a huge waste to go to law
school not knowing for sure
that you in fact want to do something
that requires a law degree.
Law school these days cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars.
It can cost over $200,000
when you factor in living expenses.
So that is a huge penalty to
pay if you aren't 100% sure
that you want to be a lawyer
or you need a law degree
for the field that you want to go into.
So while you don't need to know
exactly what you want to do,
it's a good idea to know
that you do absolutely
need a law degree.
Law school is not the time to figure out
what you want to do with your life.
So that takes me to myth number two.
And that is, "Everyone
is super competitive."
Now certainly there are going to be a lot
of competitive people.
But not everyone is a cutthroat gunner.
Just like in undergrad, there
is a huge spectrum of people
who on one side are
incredibly competitive,
and on the other side
are complete slackers.
And while there certainly
aren't as many slackers
in law school as there are in undergrad,
they certainly get into law school.
A corollary to the myth that
everyone is super competitive
is the myth that everyone
is incredibly mean.
On the contrary, I find
that law students in general
are a very kind bunch.
And some of my best friends
are the people that I met
in law school.
So don't think that you're
going to go into law school
and everyone is going to
have their nose buried
in a book all day long focused on nothing
but acing their exams.
Certainly by the time
that finals come around
everyone is probably going
to cocoon themselves,
but for the most part
law students are people
just like everybody else.
And not everyone is going to be
a super A plus type personality
that doesn't care anything
about anyone else.
Then number three is that,
"Everyone has legal experience
"before they go to law school."
Or in other words, "Everybody
knows this stuff but me."
Not true.
In fact, very few people
have legal experience
before they go to law school.
There are a handful of people
who work as paralegals,
or legal secretaries,
but here's the secret.
Even if you had those jobs
before you went to law school,
that does not prepare you for
the law school experience.
And it doesn't make you
a very good law student.
On the contrary, the
kind of day-to-day things
that paralegals do and
legal secretaries do,
the only thing I think
it would be helpful for
is civil procedure.
Other than that, they probably
have no further insights
into the substantive law
that's gonna be tested
as a 1L than anybody else.
So, in fact, very few people
have legal experience.
And even the people that
do have legal experience,
it's not the kind of experience
that's going to help them
as a law student.
So don't worry about gunners.
Gunners are very vocal.
They seem like they know
what they're talking about,
but for the most part
they're actually less likely
to do well than everybody else.
So if you did not have legal
experience before going
to law school, don't worry about it.
It's not going to help the
people that do have it.
And it's not a hindrance
to you not having it.
If you like this video, please click like
and subscribe for more
law school crushing tips.
Also please download the
checklist that's down below.
It's free and it will help
dispel all the other myths
about law school before you get there.